merci d'être avec nous ravie de vous
retrouver sur le plateau d' europe hebdo
nous sommes comme toujours au coeur du
parlement européen à bruxelles dans ce
numéro je vous propose de partir en
italie un train permettra bientôt
peut-être de relier la ville de lyon à
celle de turin projet très contesté ses
détracteurs y voient une menace pour
l'environnement est un gouffre financier
les travaux pourtant bien commencé dans
la vallée de suse nous sommes allés dans
cette vallée et sur le chantier pour
comprendre les enjeux du futur train à
grande vitesse l'actualité d'abord la
situation financière de la grèce au
coeur des préoccupations de l'europe le
problème numéro un du pays c'est la
dette véritable bombe à retardement
une histoire sans fin petit résumé en
images
c'est l'histoire d'un pays qui vivait en
permanence au bord du gouffre écrasé par
le poids de sa dette 100 80 % du produit
intérieur brut un pays où les caisses
étaient toujours vides malgré les
milliards d'euros déversés par le fmi la
banque centrale européenne et les
etats-membres
octobre 2009 georges papandréou prend
les commandes du pays son parti le pasok
a remporté les élections législatives
onze jours plus tard le nouveau premier
ministre annonce que le gouvernement
précédent à cacher l'ampleur de la dette
l'europe découvre qu'athènes a falsifié
ses comptes avec la complicité de la
banque goldman sachs
le pays connaît la plus grave crise
économique de son histoire
incapable de se financer sur les marchés
la grèce doit compter sur la solidarité
internationale
un plan de sauvetage est adoptée au
printemps 2010 même si l'allemagne
hésite longtemps avant de signer en
échange des crédits débloqués la grèce
acceptent de faire des réformes
fonctionnaires retraités sont mis au
régime sec les aides sociales réduites à
la portion congrue
l'aide ne suffit pas le pays est
toujours au bord du gouffre contraint de
demander à nouveau l'aide de ses
partenaires un deuxième plan est adopté
en 2012 et la dette grecque restructurer
et pourtant cette dernière s'aggrave
pour la population ce sont bien les
mesures d'austérité drastiques et
successives qui expliquent la
détérioration des comptes le fmi
reconnaît lui même que les exigences
imposées à athènes sont inadaptés en
janvier 2015 alexis tsipras ce
représentant de la gauche radicale
arrive au pouvoir lille dénonce le
diktat de bruxelles sur son pays et
promettent d'en finir avec l'austérité
un nouveau plan de sauvetage plus tard
le pays est toujours au pied du mur
incapable de payer ses créanciers et de
se réformer alors la dette grecque est
elle un puits sans fond une histoire
sans fin
une députée européenne nous a rejoint
sylvie goulard bonjourbonjour membres du
groupe alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe et vous avez
beaucoup écrit sur la grèce vous sortez
d'une réunion encore sur la grèce alors
180 pour cent du produit intérieur but
c'est ce que représente la dette grecque
c'est un poids est ce que on peut dire
qu'un jour
atteindra pour soi ou pas sa dette
c'est une question délicate et votre
reportage montre bien qu'il faut
remonter dans le temps le problème c'est
faire justement pour expliquer que ça
progresse oui non mais que la dette est
mathématiquement augmenté dans un pays
dont la richesse nationale se réduisait
parce que on a lancé un plan
d'assainissement budgétaire en soi c'est
mathématique ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui peut se contester en revanche ce qui
est vrai c'est que en 2010 au début de
l'histoire
on a décidé de ne pas admettre que la
dette grecque allait atteindre ces
niveaux insoutenables tu es une erreur
en tout cas ce qui est catastrophique
c'est qu'on n'ait pas eu un débat public
encore une fois c'est pas facile de
choisir entre différentes options ce qui
est particulièrement choquant c'est
qu'on a laissé entendre que cette
décision était prise uniquement à
bruxelles alors que c'est une décision
qui a été prise à la fois par le fmi
contrairement à ces pratiques la banque
centrale un ensemble de gouvernement et
que donc effectivement maintenant on a
atteint un niveau de dette qui est
difficilement soutenable et de dette
publique il faut quand même pas oublier
de la dette des créanciers privés de la
grèce a été considérablement réduite si
oui alors vous dites à l'époque on en
était là est ce qu'il y avait d'autres
choix que de faire ça quel instrument
disposer
l'europe à l'époque pour pour essayer de
régler seule au moment où la crise a
éclaté fin 2009 début 2010 la zone euro
n'avait malheureusement strictement
aucun instrument de gestion de crise on
n'avait pas prévu une détérioration des
conditions économiques et une crise
financière d'une telle ampleur donc
peut-être qu'en mai 2010 n'était pas
évident en tout cas depuis et encore une
fois notamment parce qu'en 2011 on s'est
posé la question de la dette privée on
aurait pu se poser la question de la
dette publique et à chaque fois c'est le
même scénario à athènes reçoit donc
dessoudé des milliards d'euros qui
servent à rembourser ses créanciers et
etc etc l'impression que c'est un cercle
vicieux est-ce que la stratégie est
bonne
le les gens qui disent on a aidé les
banques et pas les grecs en gros pour
faire simple sont des personnes qui sous
estiment l'importance d'un secteur
financier dans l'économie si nous
voulons que des entreprises investissent
en grèce si nous voulons que l'économie
du pays se développe eh bien il faut
bien que le pays puisse se financer sur
les marchés et que ces banques soient
solides je crois qu'il faut sortir des
contes pour petits enfants sur les
banquiers c'est les méchants les autres
célébrants en revanche il est vrai que
la priorité a été donnée à cet
assainissement financier et que nous
l'avons beaucoup dit dans ce parlement
pendant la commission barroso il n'y a
pas eu de mesures d'accompagnement qui
touché par exemple l'amélioration du
système éducatif des échanges sur
comment on met en place une formation
professionnelle comment on peut mettre
en place un système fiscal qui
permettrait de faire payer les riches
grecs qui jusqu'à présent ne payent pas
d'impôts et c'est donc à côté de
l'assainissement qui était nécessaire à
côté de la préservation d'un secteur
bancaire comme condition du redémarrage
il a manqué des politiques positives
pour aider les grecs alors pourquoi ne
pas les faire maintenant seulement vous
vous le demandez qu'est ce qui
empêcherait que qu'on puisse faire ça
avec la grèce alors d'une part il ya
l'attitude qui a été celle de ce nouveau
gouvernement qui à mon avis a gaspillé
des cartes qu'il avait en main ce
nouveau gouvernement mais pas aller vers
ses partenaires en disant je veux
absolument refonder le système fiscal
ils n'ont pas fait de proposition je dis
pas que c'est évident dans un pays où
beaucoup de gens n'ont jamais payé
d'impôts mais je crois qu'il faut
regarder les recettes autant que les
coupes dans les dépenses
par ailleurs il y a malheureusement une
absence de vision européenne d'ensemble
il n'y a pas en ce moment sur la
mobilité des travailleurs une vraie
politique européenne pas seulement pour
la grèce il n'y en a pas du tout et ça
ce sont les fire les défaillances de la
zone euro nous avons besoin d'aller
beaucoup plus loin ensemble pour faire
vivre la monnaie unique juste une
question en passant sur alexis tsipras
ce jusqu'au bout il a dit non aux
allemands non non non il a essayé de
rien lâcher est ce que c'est une bonne
méthode de négociation face à une
allemagne comme assez intransigeante
alors d'abord il n'ya pas de l'allemagne
encore une fois il est arrivé à faire
l'unanimité contre lui les 18 autres
états de la zone euro sont sur des
positions proches deuxièmement ce qui
est particulièrement regrettable c'est
qu'il ait choisi non pas une
confrontation sur un certain nombre
d'idées de fonds par exemple il aurait
pu aller à berlin avec les chiffres de
la pauvreté avec la question de la
montée des inégalités
non il est quand même allé demander
réparation de la seconde guerre mondiale
question qui avait été close en 1990 il
est en train de faire la preuve que
c'est très facile dans son propre pays
de parler de confrontation les cas
bruxelles ça n'est pas très productive
et ce qui risque d'arriver
malheureusement c'est que le peuple grec
en paye les conséquences en paient les
conséquences et ce qui risque d'arriver
aussi peut-être c'est que les extrêmes
dans ce pays d'ailleurs comme ailleurs
montrent vous le craignez vous redoutez
ce scénario oui au fond toujours
redoutée la montée de partis qui
promettent la lune et souvent n'importe
quoi qui sont parfois xénophobe parfois
anti ceni d'ailleurs la coalition qu'il
a fait est pas une coalition où il a
cherché à élargir une majorité vers le
centre de manière à avoir le soutien de
l'ensemble du pays donc il ya eu des
risques qui ont été pris par lui par
monsieur varoufakis encore une fois en
fait on refait pas l'histoire ce qui est
surtout dommage pour le peuple grec
c'est qu'en faisant perdre autant de
temps il a rendu le règlement de la
crise actuelle plus difficile et il n'a
pas été la voix des pauvres il n'a pas
été celui qui a lancé une grande réforme
fiscale s'il ya une mesure urgente à
mettre en oeuvre tout de suite pour la
grèce pour qu'elle essaye de s'en sortir
un peu ce serait laquelle si vous deviez
citer une seule non vous savez
sincèrement être une mesure je crois
qu'il faut pas raconter ça très
sincèrement il y à deux questions c'est
d'un côté les réformes du pays et de
l'autre un étalement du remboursement de
l'aller alors c'est un peu les douze
travaux d'hercule oui c'est la
mythologie grecque merci beaucoup sylvie
goulard d'avoir été avec nous pour cet
éclairage donc sur la situation de la
grèce et je vous propose ensuite de
partir en italie puisque les travaux ont
commencé pour le futur projet de train à
grande vitesse lyon turin ce projet
suscite beaucoup de critiques notamment
par rapport à son coût financier et aux
conséquences sur l'environnement nous
sommes allés sur place dans la vallée
dessus c'est un reportage signé camille
vigon le quad avec gwenaël durand
regarder
c'est ici dans ce paysage de carte
postale au coeur des alpes que doit
passer la future ligne grande vitesse
lyon turin
devant nous il ya la ville de suse voit
aussi le monde en basse marque la
frontière avec la france son âge
surnommé le taf pour trains à haute
vitesse en italien le projet prévoit de
moderniser les lignes des deux côtés de
la frontière et de creuser juste à cet
endroit un tunnel de 57 km sous les
halles le but relier paris n'en en 4
heures contre 7 aujourd'hui et diminuer
le transport authority des travaux jugés
dangereux par les opposants comme locale
on
prévoit la perte d'environ 1000 litres
d'eau par seconde et on prévoit un
impact sur les personnes fragiles des
personnes de la vallée seront malades
aggraveront leur pathologie à cause des
travaux de la ligne lyon turin
pour les défenseurs d'un pied mon sens
tgv mais bénéfices mise en avant par les
gouvernements italien et français sont
surestimés et les rapports des experts
faux ou tronquées
la nouvelle ligne qui va de turin avion
n'est pas une ligne qui transportera des
marchandises ni guy normes il y aura la
circulation des routes et des autoroutes
si jamais c'était le cas et ce n'est pas
vrai tout cela ne verra pas le jour
avant 2050 alors que nous avons besoin
de diminuer le nombre de camions et la
pollution des eaux jours de réunion
odier
un peu plus haut dans la vallée les
travaux pour le tunnel d'exploration ont
pourtant commencé
sous la montagne des tonnes de terre
sont extraites au coeur d'un chantier
gigantesque
à justin bieber est par les rails
pour le directeur général de dell tu la
société privée qui gère les travaux
l'environnement et protéger fait fermer
le chantier plus plus contrôlée de point
de vue de l'environnement il y a en
italie mettre le train au lieu des
camions c'est vraiment difficile à
démontrer il n'est pas une joueurs pour
l'environnement d'armes militaires
barbelés grillages
après de violents affrontements entre
les opposants aux travaux et les forces
de l'ordre le chantier s'est transformé
en véritable base militaire on a eu des
réactions vraiment militaire très grave
et les experts disent que
dans un 2013
celui-ci était devenu le plus important
centre de lutte
paramilitaires de guérilla d'europe
les opposants appelés no tav pour nos
autres à haute vitesse ne sont jamais
bien loin derrière le chantier dans
cette cabane en bois il attire notre
attention par des jeux de lumière
après plus de vingt ans de lutte les
habitants de la vallée ont été rejoints
par des jeunes activistes anarchistes ou
écologistes
pourtant dans le chalet de chiomonte les
irréductibles opposants ou tav semble
bien peu dans une
retraitée ou enseignants leur combat
s'ancre dans une perspective plus large
celle d'un autre modèle de croissance
ce n'est pas une peur contre la
modernité c'est la peur de perdre le
concept de modernité l'homme moderne
devrait être un homme intelligent
pensant alors que l'homme moderne
aujourd'hui se fait toujours plus
convaincre par des paroles sans vérifier
si derrière il ya du contenu sur des
comptes est monté
certains opposants historiques ont
pourtant rejoint les rangs des
défenseurs du projet convaincu à présent
que la ligne lyon-turin modifier ces
dernières années est une chance pour la
région pour l'europe antonio ferentino a
retourné sa veste
le projet dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
utilisent totalement la ligne
ferroviaire actuel donc il n'y a aucune
dévastation de la vallée de suse car
dans la vallée il n'y a pas de travaux
tous les villages sont protégés et
moules sont divins de numico ce temps je
suis devenu l'ennemi historique du
mouvement no tav en effet j'ai fait
l'objet d'une campagne diffamatoire je
suis le trait sur une île près du pauvre
sur la route de turin les stigmates du
conflit sont bien visibles déjà retardé
depuis plusieurs années la ligne
lyon-turin attend maintenant que l'union
européenne débloque les 40% de
financement promis estimé à 26 milliards
d'euros le projet pharaonique devrait
continuer de susciter ces prochaines
années de détention
voilà pour ce projet aux enjeux
écologiques économiques et financiers
importants nous sommes revenus à
bruxelles pour en parler avec deux
députées européennes
mercedes bresso bonjour bonjour alors
vous venez d'italie vous êtes membre du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates et
vous faites partie ici de la commission
du développement et vous connaissez bien
ce projet puisque vous l'avez un peu
porter ou même si je puis dire en tant
que présidente de la région de turin
avant on va en parler dans un instant
vous êtes face à karima delli bonjour
bonjour vous êtes dans le groupe des
verts membre de la commission des
transports vous connaissez aussi très
bien ce sujet vous n'êtes pas forcément
favorable à peut-être la première
question avoue mercedes bresso puisque
vous avez des directement suivi le début
de ces projets de ce projet qui suscite
un tas de polémiques on va que c'est que
ça a beaucoup de saveur à avoir des
conséquences négatives sur la santé que
les retombées connery seront pas assurés
est ce que pour vous c'est quand même
une route d'avenir pour l'europe alors
c'est sûrement un groupe d'avenir pour
l'europe ça c'est vous savez dans les
grandes connexion entre entre européenne
c'est la route du sud eux c'est celle
que depuis lisbonne devra mener jusqu'à
nous traîne avec laquelle qui ne sera
pas partie de l'union européenne mais
qui avec laquelle on a des rapports
importants et d'autres c'est la graine
de lignes de transport ferroviaire du
sud de l'europe ça modernise en ligne
qui existaient déjà et qui maintenant ne
parlait plus de d'une façon économique
et écologique de transporter sur tous
les machins dire les personnes et les
marchandises
marc je suis vivre la conté malade
depuis le début parce que j'étais
président de la province de turin quand
on a fait les toutes les premières
évaluations quand on a changé le projet
mais c'est maintenant le raconter on l'a
changé complète est comme ça et dès le
début de la contestation
vous étiez confrontés aux contestataires
de ce projet dès le début oui oui
absolument
et ce qui me fait un peu rire c'est que
on vient de doubler le tunnel
ferroviaire dans la valette le tunnel
excusez-moi autoroutier dans la même
balle et il ya pas eu de contestations
un tunnel c'est un tunnel nous on
l'italie vous savez un couvert de
montagne ont fait des tunnels tout le
temps et partout parce que sinon on
pourrait pas faire aucune connexion donc
les techniques sont toujours le même
celui là du point de vue technique et un
défi un peu plus importante mais du
point de vue environnemental et il n'y a
aucune différence parce que sentinelle
mme entre l'ol a dit là toujours il
entrait et sortait alors c'est pas
forcément ce que vous pensez vous karima
delli vous êtes plutôt contre ce projet
pourquoi nous les écologistes on est
content pour conduire raisons d'une part
c'est un projet qui nous ne pouvait être
utile il ya 20 ans aujourd'hui on voit
le trafic notamment de marchandises
s'est réduit de manière considérable
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose qui est important c'est un projet
qui est dévastateur pour l'environnement
parce qu'on va percer notamment ce
tunnel dans de la roche amiante et c'est
à dire que des particules vont
être dans les paysages c'est la première
chose on va utiliser des milliers de
deux terrains de terre viable et ensuite
et on l'a dit un reportage qui est très
bien fait d'ailleurs on va utiliser
l'eau donc les conséquences elles ont
direct en termes de santé publique pour
les citoyens savent eux des vestes et
quoi le paysage même un chasseur ou
considère que non
mercedes bresso nous dit que l'italie
est déjà percés par des tunnels de
toutes parts alors il faut croire que
l'avenir ne se regarde avec les lunettes
du passé il faut arrêter de croire que
le progrès c'est des grands projets
inutiles la véritable question est là on
revient sur des problèmes économiques et
financiers
lorsqu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui que ce
tunnel ce grand projet va nous coûter 26
milliards d'euros l'europe pourrait être
amenée à financer 40 % du projet mais il
faut que l'italie et la france j'ai 63
ans et problème apparaît déjà sur
l'environnement karima delli
les aspects économiques personne
tranquille que ça remontera le pilot
européenne n'est pas n'importe quel pays
l'europe et le pit ppb pardon des des
régions et des pays du sud de l'europe
parce que sans une grande ligne de
transport ferroviaire au sud de l'europe
tous les trafics vont se déplacer au
niger pour le développer la ligne mais
parce qu'on n'a pas un système de
transport ferroviaire efficace vous
savez qui sont d'ailleurs déjà en train
de percer les pyrénées est donc cette
ligne est en train de se mettre en place
elle a déjà réalisé dans beaucoup de
parties donc elle sait qu'on stable
économiquement puisque les absolument
être l'occasion de la réhabiliter tous
ceux qui travaillent sur l'économie des
transports monsieur économistes
d'information savent très bien que c'est
l'offre qui est en train de la demande
dans le secteur des transports
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec le tgv
et le jour et se remplit parce qu'il
existe sinon les gens auraient tout
simplement abandonné le train ce qui
d'ailleurs est arrivé en italie où les
lignes à grande vitesse ont été retardés
on allez avant tout le temps en voiture
maintenant plus personne prend la
voiture ou l'avion depuis milan as rome
etc
les questions d'environnement
oui alors c'est évident que dans toute
opération de cette dimension d'un
travail de cette dimension on doit faire
attention mais la pente mais qui va se
retrouver et de
matériaux radioactifs et c est
exactement la même que si on fait un
tunnel de 10 km aux mêmes de
510 il faut vérifier et c'est déjà prévu
que si on trouve des matériaux qui sont
à risque ils soient laissées dans la
montagne il ya évidemment des ddd
espèce de trou dans des grottes dans
lesquels on a actuellement on installe
les taux de tout le matériel équipement
et on pourra l'utiliser pour laisser là
la partie éventuellement dangereuse mais
au fond dans le monde connais très bien
la géologie de cette montagne on vient
de faire complètement en tunnel une
centrale hydroélectrique et on connaît
très bien ce qu'il y a dans cet endroit
là il n'y a pas à cette profondeur il
n'y aura pas de l'amiante qui est en
surface il ya eu beaucoup de rapports
d'experts karima delli sur sur 7 sur ce
projet vous n'êtes pas convaincu partie
alors quand le chef de chantier dit
c'est le chantier le plus le plus sur
les eaux de l'environnement il dit
c'est totalement faux parce que même les
études géologiques faite par le lyon
turin ma montre qu'il ya de l'amiante et
on ne dit aucunement qu'elles sont les
scion on va prendre pour résoudre ces
problématiques notamment pour les
riverains donc ça c'est la première
chose vous avez parlé des questions
socio-économiques faut rappeler que la
cour des comptes a remis plusieurs
rapports pour dire en français en table
pour moi parce que à chaque kilomètre
chaque kilo mais va nous coûter des
millions d'euros pourquoi à la fin pour
avoir 26 milliards d'euros mais surtout
on nous n'avons aucune donnée
n'est pas sûr mais quand même aucune
donnée fiable en termes d'emplois dans
ce carré entre 2000 et 3000 les vous
rendez compte 26 milliards d'euros
d'investissements écouter sans will à
2,5 cette loi
pour alors 1000 où il faut alors mille
emplois donc ça veut dire que c'est rien
n'empêche mieux investi 1 26 milliard
mais on est expert des lumières c'est
chacun peut me dit oui et comme il les
chiffres peut rayonner 108 85 milliards
et le projet est définitif donc on sait
très bien combien ça va coûter et
n'oublions pas que ça c'est un passage
d'une ligne de milliers de kilomètres et
donc quand on doit passer les alpes
c'est un peu plus tôt qu'ailleurs pour
des projets pour concasser là vous êtes
ado dont vous êtes élus le projet coup
de la finale hier la russie membre de la
commission transports et jean lui dire
que toutes les études de l'arrivée je
vis en france mais c'est vrai nous
sommes pas dans le débat nous parlons du
lyon turin dans l'ensemble à bientôt
n'aura pas de problème mais la mienne
n'aura pas énorme problème ça là on est
un sport se déplacer au nord donc je
voudrais pour pour dépasser cette
bataille de chiffres essayez de voir une
autre critique sur ce projet qui
concerne la manière dont tu aurais étè
passé certains marchés c'est en tout cas
ce que nous dit il personne qu'on a
interviewé pour ce reportage écouter
dans 28 20 ans la ligne lyon turin est
soutenue par des personnes qu'ils se
trompent dans les prévisions
et qui ont des conflits d'intérêts
terrifiant
les mêmes personnes ont été nommés par
le gouvernement comme commissaire
extraordinaire président de la
commission intergouvernementale et
président de l'observatoire
aujourd'hui sont administrateur délégué
de la société privée qui doit réaliser
la construction
c'est un énorme conflit d'intérêts et sa
mine à la base n'importe quelle
discussion sérieuse sur ce projet
alors karima delli j'ai eu un recours
déposés auprès de l'office antifraude
européen est ce que vous avez une
réponse qu'il a des chances d'aboutir et
à quoi il faut faut dire que ce projet
il ya énormément de soupçons de
corruption
d'infiltration de la mafia des choix que
nous disent ces retrouvailles au point
que l'olaf a ouvert une enquête parce
qu'elle a des éléments pour ouvrir une
enquête le lhc l'office
antifraude au niveau européen nous
attendons ses conclusions mais ce que je
dis c'est avant de faire quoi que ce
soit sur ce projet attendons les
conclusions de la lawe parce que s'ils
aulas et mais elle a bien dans we had à
ba2 la fraude oui il ya bien de la
corruption c'est aussi le projet
européen qui est entachée mercedes
bresso qu'elle ne se savait que
dans tout grand projet c'est risque
existe donc c'est juste de contrôler il
ya des mesures très spécial la procédure
vous dites c'est l'adversité c'est tout
à fait normal qu'on vérifie et s'il ya
des problèmes c'est pas qu'on renonce à
l'oeuvre on prend les mesures
nécessaires pour estomper la corruption
et ça c'est valable on l'a fait pour
l'expo 2000 arrête tout et tout a bien
marché je voulais voir plus de choses
que ce tunnel le tunnel à tirer de tout
cela devrait encore utilisé il à 150 3
et les tunnels du mont ce alors celui là
ses villages ses rassemblements sait
mais qui vise à remplacer
c'est sous le fréjus c'est juste à côté
c'est les deux montagnes à côté la nôtre
est rationnel a été ternie né en 1870 et
donc 150 ans pour way et il a duré et il
a été utilisé pendant 150 ans c'est pour
ça que quand on parle de perspectives
économiques ou personne de noces et
qu'est-ce qui se passera dans les
prochaines 150 ans ce qu'on doit faire
ce m apesud est nos systèmes de
transport pour actualiser oui alors le
mot de la fin karima delli est le mot de
la fin c'est qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
engager l'argent public européen sur ce
genre de projet parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya aucune y aura moi je considère turin
des problèmes environnementaux des
problèmes économique parce qu'à pas de
retour sur investissement mais surtout
et c'est en un peu anti démocratique les
no tav ils sont là pour ce sont des
habitants dans la vallée qui disent bon
mais laissez nous vivre avec notre
paysage tel qu'il est dense et aussi je
ne va pas changer parce que comme ça a
été rappelé on a modifié le projet qui
actuellement ne touche en aucune manière
la vallée voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de nous avoir
éclairé sur ce projet lyon turin
je vous donne rendez-vous à très bientôt
sur les chaînes parlementaires bail